[Music]
Big Bang Theory which shoots on this lot
and we're grateful cuz they're great
cast and they visit us all the time Big
Bang Theory is now being credited with
leading kids to pursue science as a
career it's getting kids interested in
science not something you intended no
but yeah we've seen some articles where
more kids are going into the hard
sciences math physics things like that
as a result of watching the show which
is nice because prior to that cheers led
them to alcoholism was the message of
Cheers
you know and Seinfeld taught people to
just be dicks to one another so yeah
we're turning him on the science very
nice well let's talk about the book what
doesn't kill us makes us better this is
an interesting idea and I noticed this a
while ago there's something in
television called vanity cards I'm sure
you all know folks what the end of a TV
show you see a logo that comes up it's
the producer has created this show for
quite a while we've had Kona Co has been
our logo JJ Abrams uses bad robot little
robot that's running around in a field
and old burger sit Ubu sit
boo sit when you get to know it you do
interesting thing everyone else has one
and they just have it come up at the end
you decided at some point to make a
different vanity card for every episode
of the show little si oneís yeah a
little you'd write messages yeah how did
you get that idea why you like liner
notes for an album does anyone remember
album
[Applause]
how's it computer dating so-so
so you said okay I want to create
specific things for each show
it started on dharma & greg 1997 or
something like that right and and no one
could read them because there was VCRs
it was before the DVR so you couldn't
really pause and read it and so it was
fairly you know benign no one can read
it i didn't get in too much trouble then
and then DVRs came along and people
could pause on it they could freeze it
and read your message now lawyers are
involved right because you were you were
writing stuff that that some people
found what controversial yeah there was
a couple of times the CBS executives and
ABC before that were unhappy with them
yeah right so there's a bunch of
censored once and I couldn't air there
in the book but by the way the book all
the proceeds go to charity so it's a
really nice thing to get as a Christmas
gift or something like that
well you know first of all I really
didn't through the book today and really
enjoying the the notes that you had
written and then I found out that this
all goes to charity and it's a specific
charity
it's the Venice free clinic the Venice
free clinic in Los Angeles how did you
choose that charity when I was in my 20s
a long time ago I got really sick and I
and I had nowhere to go I couldn't I
didn't have any money for a doctor and
so when I when I when I was in a
position to get involved with somebody
that does something good I wanted to do
something with a group of people that
make sure you get to see a doctor no
matter what so I don't want to go into
the details of what I had to do to see a
doctor back in the 70s but it's not
pleasant so I like now I have to ask you
what did you have to do really yeah go
for it why not there's a thing called a
teaching hospital where you get examined
by medical students in exchange for free
medical help so what I had I had OSA
rate of colitis so I had a class of
medical students giving me an anesthetic
free colonoscopy Mike
which I found to be particularly useful
for when I got into television
[Laughter]
[Applause]